this is lithium pretty soon we're going
to need a lot of it lithium is a useful
metal it spends its entire existence
trying to get rid of its one outer
electron but crucially this reaction can
be both controlled and reversed that
means properly configured the metal can
discharge energy when needed take in
more energy and then discharge that
energy essentially it can act as a
battery it's only been a few decades
since Lithium-ion batteries reach
commercial feasibility but in that time
they have become the power source of
choice for portable Electronics thanks
to their Perfect Blend of safety and
lightness however the latest major Tech
Boom the latest infatuation of Silicon
Valley and Wall Street alike is centered
around the largest consumer electronics
product to date electric vehicles and
pretty soon we're going to need a lot of
them the UK for example has committed to
Banning internal combustion car sales by
2030. to replace its three one and a
half million Vehicles about 236 000
metric tons of lithium carbonate are
needed to produce 236 000 metric tons of
lithium carbonate every lithium mine in
the world would have to devote its
output to this one use for nine months
and there are a whole lot more countries
a whole lot more lithium applications
and a whole lot more growth in the
forecast while the industry and its
issues may be complex the way in which
battery grade lithium is produced is not
four countries dominate the industry
Argentina Chile Australia and China
combined account for 92 percent of the
globe's production the medal is
extracted from the ground at massive
sites like the green Bush's mine in
Western Australia which is the world's
largest Hard Rock lithium mine this is
elected due to the abundance of
spotamine in the area which is a mineral
that contains large concentrations of
lithium once the raw material is
extracted from the ground is transported
two and a half hours North to the
quinana lithium plant near Perth a
facility a majority owned and operated
by a Chinese company chunky lithium
which is responsible for almost half of
the world's production of the metal once
refined lithium hydroxide and other
compounds are sold to battery
manufacturers which in about three
quarters of a cases means one of three
companies LG chem catl or Panasonic the
problem however is the world's solution
in addition to the UK Iceland Belgium
the Netherlands Germany Denmark Norway
Sweden Israel Singapore and South Korea
have each committed to Banning the sale
of internal combustion passenger
vehicles within the next decade adding
up their annual passenger vehicle sales
numbers from 2019 that means the
absolute base case demand for EVS a
decade from now will be 9.5 million per
year just to reach that Eevee production
would have to to quintuple but even the
most conservative forecasters don't dare
tread anywhere close to a number as low
as 9.5 million in 2032 the market is
waking up to what this means for lithium
demand across 2021 seaborne lithium
Prices rose from around 8 000 per metric
ton to over thirty thousand dollars a
400 rise in a mere 12 months and lithium
is hardly the only crucial medal for
lithium-ion battery production it's just
the one in the name Cobalt and nickel
are also critical to most commercially
available versions of these batteries
and the situation is hardly different
with them Cobalt prices doubled across
2021 while nickel Rose to its highest
price in a decade so the world needs a
lot more Metals but right now it's hard
to believe the world's going to get them
the biggest hurdle the industry faces is
exemplified here Thacker pass Nevada
Thacker pass is located in one of the
most sparsely populated areas of the
country it's a half hour's drive to the
nearest store an hour to the nearest
supermarket and three to the nearest
Starbucks the few roads that exist in
the area are lucky to see a few cars an
hour traveling to and from the various
remote Farms ranches and communities
dotting Northern Nevada that could soon
change though 250 miles or 400
kilometers to the South is the Silver
Peak lithium mine this is the nation's
only currently operating major lithium
mine despite the fact that the US is one
of the largest ev markets and home to
the world's largest ev manufacturer
China also major EV Market home to Major
EV manufacturers has made significant
Headway in building up its domestic
lithium production capacity and the
country's companies also have
significant presences at the world's
other major lithium production sites
this has come to concern those in charge
in the U.S therefore sites are set on
Thacker pasts home to the US's largest
lithium deposits the site could still
handily propel Propel us into the ranks
of major lithium producers but getting a
mine up and running there has proved
difficult the way in which major lithium
deposits are distributed across the
world is rather cruel overwhelmingly
they're located in arid regions with
little water availability like Nevada
Thacker pass receives less than 10
inches or 25 centimeters of rain a year
however the extraction and processing of
lithium requires enormous quantities of
water it's expected that operations at
the proposed Thacker past lithium mine
would require
3224 gallons or 12 204 liters of water
per minute roughly equivalent to the
contents of a backyard above ground pool
that water would be used to pump into
the ground as part of the extraction
process during refinement and to conduct
necessary dust control at the site to
get this water the mind would have to
pump it out of the ground using Wells
but every acre foot of water in the area
is strictly allocated given the degree
of scarcity so the mine has to buy up
water rights from others in order to
gain the legal right to use it what that
that means however is that there's a
direct trade-off between one use and
another and in this case the other use
is predominantly ranching and farming
two key tenants to the local economy in
addition there's a chance the project
could do far more to further the
inaccessibility of water in Northern
Nevada the U.S Bureau of Land
Management's environmental impact study
for the project found that it presented
the distinct possibility of leaking
unacceptable levels of arsenic into the
area's groundwater table which could
take the entire Region's water supply
offline for hundreds of years in an area
where the availability of water
undergirds almost all economic activity
that has people seriously concerned the
issues only Compound on top of that as
thakrapas is of course a mountain pass
it acts as a wildlife Corridor between
the Double H and Montana mountains two
biodiversity hot spots therefore the
environmental impact study found the
project likely to destroy or deteriorate
thousands of Acres of habitat used by
the pronghorn antelope Sage grouse
golden eagle and other unique species
for interrelated reasons the project
also has a number of local indigenous
tribes concerned the most vocal of which
is the Fort McDermott payute and
Shoshone tribe they say that during the
era of American soldiers rounding up and
shipping indigenous people off to
reservations two of the tribe's families
hid out in the shelter Thacker past
provided so they directly attribute the
continued existence of their tribe to
the area in addition they consider the
past a sacred site in part because of a
historic Massacre they say occurred
there this assertion however was
directly challenged in a court case
related to the mine project and the
judge rejected the claim citing a lack
of evidence to add to their opposition
the try put forward evidence linking the
development of similar resource
extraction projects which are
predominantly staffed by men to
increases in the rape and murder of
indigenous women in nearby areas even
just looking at these few headline
issues it becomes clear that the Thacker
pass lithium mine project is mired in a
nearly insurmountable web of controversy
and conflict and it's hardly alone in
that status much of the evidence
opponents to the Thacker past mine have
put forward is based on real world
experiences in the lithium triangle the
Nexus between Chile Argentina and
Bolivia that host some of the world's
most productive lithium production
facilities an area in a similar
situation a remote arid landscape
punctuated by small communities home to
a historically oppressed indigenous
population the lithium triangle has seen
an economic Boon but it's come at the
cost of Environmental and Cultural
Devastation just as the issues are not
confined to one geography they're not
even confined to lithium alone some 70
of the world's Cobalt a crucial
component to current battery Tech comes
from the Democratic Republic of the
Congo the eighth poorest country in the
world according to World Bank figures
while a majority of the Cobalt mining is
conducted by large mining companies with
often shaky safe safety and human rights
records a concerningly large minority is
accomplished through what's referred to
as artisanal mining a term defining the
illegal informal practice of individuals
mining Cobalt by themselves and selling
it on to Shady middlemen the complete
lack of safety standards or regulations
in the sector means child labor and
deadly mind collapses are rampant for
those that aren't directly injured or
killed on the job long-term exposure to
Cobalt mines has been linked to
significant health effects later in life
and fatal birth defects for children in
the region altogether there's almost no
such thing as ethical Cobalt there's
also almost no such thing as green
lithium there's little appetite anywhere
to increasing lithium mining in the
places where it's accessible and little
progress has been made in the DRC in
making Cobalt mining less socially
disastrous as demand for EVS and their
batteries increases getting more Cobalt
and lithium will be incredibly difficult
however on top of that getting more
Cobalt and lithium that's more ethical
and green or even as ethical and green
will be next to Impossible but to
decarbonize driving solution must be
found one option rather than finding
more raw materials is to need less of
them of course the way to do that is by
making batteries better the most
promising short-term Innovation that
could fulfill that mission is solid
state batteries whereas traditional EV
batteries have a liquidy viscous
lithium-based electrolyte solid-state
batteries rather use a solid metal
composition as their ion transport
mechanism this switch has a number of
benefits including a higher safety
profile that reduces the risk of fire
and therefore reduces the need for
expensive safety features solid state
batteries can also be made without
Cobalt or nickel which eliminates two
problematic and costly Necessities in
current battery Tech most significant
however is solid-state batteries higher
energy density traditional lithium-ion
compositions used in EV battery packs
store about 114 Watt hours of energy per
pound or 250 per kilogram that means one
pound of battery could move a Tesla
Model 3 for example 0.4 miles or 1
kilogram 1.3 kilometers meanwhile it's
expected that solid state batteries will
be able to store between 175 and 225
Watt hours per pound or 400 to 500 per
kilogram essentially doubling battery
density that means Tesla could have the
weight of their half ton battery pack
and not only keep range the same but
increase it as the car would no longer
need to carry the rest of the weights of
the battery pack on top of all those
benefits experts believe that at scale
production costs of solid state
batteries could be even less than the
current cheapest lithium ion batteries
however the issue is getting to that
scale battery production needs to occur
at absolutely massive quantities to
reach cost competitiveness an assertion
backed up by the industry's current
effective triopoly the process of
working down this cost curve is long as
there are few applications where battery
weight matters as much as with EVs and
EVS won't switch to solid-state
batteries until their cost is
competitive but their cost will only
become competitive when the industry is
a production capacity that only EVS can
provide so the industry has to wait for
some level of scale to occur through
Niche solid-state battery applications
in medical devices race cars and fighter
jets then wait for Consumer Electronics
to realize the weight savings or battery
life benefits The Innovation could
provide then wait for the highest end
EVS to incorporate the technology in
order to offer super long ranges as a
luxury before solid-state batteries can
finally reach a cost that would allow
them to permeate into what will be by
then the large segment of everyday EVS
most estimates place that enticing end
goal more than a decade away even if the
solid state battery transition reaches
fruition earlier the world will still
need a whole lot more lithium far from
the potential environmental disaster at
Thacker pass is an existing
environmental disaster the salt and sea
a century ago Colorado River flood
waters breached through an irrigation
canal and accumulated over years in the
Imperial Valley's Geographic low Point
236 feet or 72 meters below sea level
that massive puddle still exists today
but some of the water has slowly
evaporated Through Time leaving uneven
saltier dirtier accumulation of water
thousands more feet below however are a
number of underground volcanoes that
superheat water to hundreds of degrees
if one brings that water to the surface
the pressure change leads to it
transforming into steam and steam of
course is what most power plants use to
drive turbines traditional power plants
use coal or natural gas to heat water up
into steam but this steam is created by
the Earth meaning it's carbon free
that's why Berkshire Hathaway energy has
built 10 geothermal energy plants in the
area but crucially this superheated
water is filled with something else
lithium therefore these geothermal
plants are planning on adding an extra
step in their process to extract lithium
from the Briny steam they use now there
are certainly significant technological
hurdles that stand between now and a
future of commercially competitive
lithium production at the Salton Sea
especially as the metal only represents
a tiny portion of the slurry of
materials found in the water but the
lithium is there Berkshire Hathaway
energy is the largest existing Energy
company working around the Salton Sea is
leading the charge thanks in part to a
sizeable Federal Grant and expects to
have its demonstration facility up and
running later in 2022. a number of other
competitors have already started
developing their lithium extraction
plays around the Salton Sea meaning
America's first lithium Boom Town might
already be a 4 gone conclusion these are
the kind of solutions needed as the
world transitions to Electric Mobility
electric vehicles due to their Reliance
on batteries are just dirtier than
internal combustion vehicles to produce
that being said the vast majority of
emissions from Cars including from EVS
themselves come not from the production
of vehicles but from driving them the
science on the issue is Sound electric
vehicles from production to use to
scrapping are responsible for about 75
percent less emissions than their
internal combustion counterparts even on
current fossil fuel based electric grids
anyone who argues the opposite is either
misinformed or attempting to disinform
and that Gap will only widen as grids
continue to decarbonize however there
can be better alternatives to better
Alternatives in the coming lithium Gold
Rush Corners can and likely will be cut
the question the world will have to
Grapple with is whether it's worth
destroying pristine environments like
hacker pass in the name of
environmentalism whether slowing the
issue on a global level is worth
accelerating it on a local level then
when the answer inevitably gravitates
towards yes the world will have to
Grapple with who must confront that
local Devastation if the enter continues
to be to place the burden on the world's
most vulnerable then even if the steady
March of climate change is curbed will
the world have truly succeeded in
stopping its effects is it worth sending
teenagers to die in a war to prevent the
propagation of terrorist organizations
is it worth depressing an economy to
slow the spread of a pandemic is it
worth allowing individuals to own guns
for cell protection even if it allows
easier access for Bad actors determining
what is an acceptable sacrifice has
historically led to some of the most
contentious perennial political issues
in history
here it's happening again the public
needs to decide with the fate of the
world on top of them how much bad should
be allowed for the greater Goods
if you want to reduce your impact on the
environment one great place to start is
with hellofresh hellofresh is a meal kit
service that ships all the ingredients
you need for their recipes and exactly
the quantities you need the packaging is
made out of 100 recycled content and a
University of Michigan study found that
hellofresh cut down on food waste by 25
percent compared to grocery shopping
that makes your meals Greener or put on
top of that hellofresh makes cooking a
lot more convenient thanks to those
pre-portioned ingredients your shopping
time becomes none and your prep time is
reduced so it means you can make fresh
home-cooked meals in less time I love
the concept so much that I used
hellofresh for almost a year before they
came along and sponsored us and still do
to this day for example last week I had
the parmesan chicken with garlic
scallions couscous and Lemony roasted
carrots for dinner which as always was
delicious and hellofresh also makes
things easier for you if you're counting
calories since they just tell you the
nutritional info for each of their meals
no more adding up all the ingredients or
approximating altogether I love
hellofresh since it reduces my
dependence on unhealthy and expensive
freezer and delivery food and helps me
free up time so I'd encourage you to try
them out click the button on screen or
go to hellofresh.com and use code
wendover16 for up to 16 free meals and
three surprise gifts